quand tu es abandonné ça te donne une
rage de vivre incontrôlable mais tu
reste prisonnier de ta colère est ce que
vous êtes encore oui je pense que je le
suis parce que vraiment en fait
ce que je tiens vraiment à préciser
c'est que je suis pas au courant de ce
que je découvre dans mon dossier et
découvrir que l aile
elle a 14 ans et que ces thèmes ont été
bien plus âgé et qu' elle connaissait
rien lui cetera il ya ce doute qui se
sème qui est de peut-être se dire
qu'elle a été violée
il ya un double deuil fr il ya le deuil
de la réalité il ya le deuil du rêve
parce que olivier a construit une
finition toute sa vie sur son histoire
familiale et quand il découvre que ça
coïncide pas avec la fiction qu'il a
imaginé c'est un double traumatisant si
vous étiez métis en fait vous rendez
compte que vous êtes de deux parents
noirs apparemment donc effectivement il
ya la raison c'est c'est sain c'est vrai
que c'est en fait c'est ça c'est
important ce que vous dites c'est que la
réalisatrice à la fin me disent que tu
te sens plus libre et je dis c'est pas
parce qu'on a des réponses qu'on sent
plus libre ça ouvre d'autres questions
et est la plus grosse question que j'ai
aujourd'hui c'est dire et peut-être que
je vous rejoins là est-ce que je ne suis
pas en train d'ouvrir une porte qui est
lui fera du mal parce qu'elle essaie
d'oublier mais ce que je tiens à vous
dire aussi c'est que ceux de se dire
vous êtes un cauchemar pour votre mère
biologique
c'est aussi une acceptation de soi qui
est complètement différent tout donc je
vous rejoins dans cette souffrance que
je me dis est-ce que j'ai permis la
faire souffrir mais moi je souffre et
oui part peut-être pur égoïsme ou
narcissisme je suis allé dans cette
recherche pensant comité par défaut pour
maintenant je le sais mais c'est une
minéralité et peut-être que j'avais
envie qu'elle me tende la main comme je
tendrai la main mais peut-être que tout
simplement aujourd'hui s'étaient pas
manifestés comme vous dites c'est parce
qu'elle a pendant une mi temps de cette
main elle a surtout envie d'oublier ce
qu'elle a dit à 34 ans c'est un
cauchemar et j'ai envie de tout oublier
je me suis juste dit qu'après trente
quatre ans telles que les dix ans lors
d'un jour on pourrait lui parler dans
l'exemple de l'accord exprès du tout à
l'heure vous avez des enfants devenus
adultes bien sûr qu'ils ne peuvent pas
parler la même langue dont qui sont
obligés de passer par un traducteur et
là c'est absolument terrible parce que
les parents les enfants peuvent pas se
parler et donc quand le traducteur n'est
plus la mort l indice passe plus rien il
regagne chacun leur foyer respectif